mais
à m'embêter
la garde du roi lion la prise de pouvoir
de makou on y est presque
qu'est ce que tu vas au nom des liens
des sapins du vautour lem shakai le
tournage dit peu importe ce que cette la
gare du roi lion la peur de rien
attendre je vois que je vois quelque
chose
vous
quoi c'est tout oh non on attend rapport
il n'y a pas de quoi s'emballer ce n'est
qu'un dame en point ce dans un buisson
moment méprise ou blague c'est pas si
grave à leur nom on n'a forcé de la part
du lion jusqu'ici pour sa bong a le
devoir de la garde du roi lion et de
préserver le cycle de la vie même si ça
se résume à aider un damman à sortir
d'un buisson plein des pin bon d'accord
je m'en occupe
allez viens petit coca je vais toujours
qu'il la tue c'est je crois qu'il veut
pas sortir parce qu'il a peur d'être
blessé par les épines en traversant le
buisson sa ponette enregis mans ils
peuvent facilement d'être heures le bus
sont si qu'aion peut détruire à buisson
avec son rugissement
est-ce que tu imagines ce qui arrivera à
ce pauvre dame en eau
j'avais pas pensé à ceux des de toute
façon on n'a pas besoin de mon registre
mans pour se débarrasser de quelques
ronces il suffit des cartes et un peu
les branches où tu as raison soucaze à
l'étude à mon sens de la réponse arrive
merci folie bien jouer banger moi
regarder ce qu'il fait c'est bizarre il
doit vraiment adoré ses potes
serpenteaux l'on en fait il se sert de
l'aude lors de la peau de serpent pour
masquer la sienne et éviter qu'un autre
serpent faire sa présence c'est plutôt
molle face il ya un serpent juste
derrière toi qu'elle vient de sommeil
l'ati seconde fois les pierrots qu'est
ce que tu t'es à oui je te conseille de
manger autre chose
et en parlant de moules voyant si
j'arrive à atteindre l'île
lumières cela tu avais mon gars tu en
odeur est encore plus effrayante que
celle d'un serpent merci je le prends
comme un compliment
tu devrais pas tout va bien bastille ah
oui ce sont ces fleurs et cette boue qui
m'ont rendu un petit peu collant c'est
pour lula je crois que je vais devoir
prendre un bain les toits bon gars
c'était quand la dernière fois que tu as
pris un dom est-ce que ça compte la
dernière fois je suis tombé dans une
cascade